Speaker 1: All right, I want to talk a little
bit about Democratic Congressman Jamie Raskin,
Jamie Raskin is a super interesting guy. Many
of you e-mailed me when I said last week,
who are interesting candidates on the Democratic
side, if Joe Biden were not to run for reelection.
Many of you wrote in about Jamie Raskin, and
I'm going to talk about that in a moment. But
the news with Jamie Raskin is that in a
recent interview, he says straight up,
Trump will be held accountable for his crime
wave. There will be consequences to Donald Trump
for the things that he did. There's a Newsweek
article about this which we will look at guilty
as sin. Jamie Raskin promises Trump will
answer for crime wave. Representative
Jamie Raskin from Maryland has labeled former
President Donald Trump quote guilty as sin,
while vowing that he will get his comeuppance
over the January 6th attack on the U.S. Capitol.
Raskin, a member of the House Jan. six committee,
described Trump as a one man crime wave during a
recent salon interview. Attorney General Merrick
Garland filed seditious conspiracy charges against
members of the far right Oath Keepers militia
group, Raskin noted, before suggesting Garland
may also choose to eventually bring criminal
charges against the former president. People
were on Garland's case about the fact that there
had been no indictments for seditious conspiracy,
and then there was a huge indictment on seditious
conspiracy against the Oath Keepers, Raskin told
Salon's Dean Obeidallah. And presumably more to
come. They obviously weren't the only group there.
There were overlap. There were these overlapping
circles of conspiracy to knock over the Capitol
and take down our government and the key moment.
Trump will get his comeuppance. Jamie Raskin says
I know how maddening and frustrating it is
to people. I share the feeling. Having been
an impeachment manager, he's as guilty as sin.
He's a one man crime wave. And it's amazing that
his dad's money and this pack of lawyers that
he travels with have been able to get him off
everything up until now. I have to tell you that
I, of course, hope that Jamie Raskin is correct.
I am very skeptical that Jamie Raskin is correct,
and I don't doubt his intentions, and I don't
doubt his commitment to holding Trump accountable
for all or some of the things that he did.
But I am extraordinarily skeptical that Trump
is going to really face consequences beyond, you
know, maybe not having a viable candidacy in 2024.
But the thing I want to bring up with you now and
kind of chat about is I like Jamie Raskin. Jamie
Raskin as a Democratic presidential candidate
is interesting to me. And of course, I'm not
suggesting Joe Biden be primaried, although I
have no moral opposition to it, although I think
strong primary challenges to a sitting president
are likely to hurt that party. But you guys know
I don't care about the Democratic Party in any
in any serious way. I care about who are the best
people. I think a lot of you guys have convinced
me that Jamie Raskin is someone that should be at
least thought about as a potential presidential
candidate in the future. Constitutional law
professor by trade of progressive activists
like an actual activist, he was actual
member of the Progressive Caucus endorsed
by the Bernie affiliated PAC Our Revolution.
I mean that this is a progressive guy by every
reasonable assessment worked for the separation
of church and state. True separation of church
and state worked to ban discrimination on the
basis of sexual orientation and gender identity.
Did a great job during Donald Trump's second
impeachment trial. The I hate to say it, but
I think one of the issues someone like
Jamie Raskin comes up against is not
insignificant amounts of anti-Semitism in
the United States, and I don't mean just on
the right. I've talked before about left wing
anti-Semitism and think back to the year 2000,
when Joe Lieberman was Al Gore's vice presidential
running mate. Joe Lieberman was the epitome of
like the uncontroversial centrist moderate. You
know, there was much more concern about the fact
that Joe Lieberman wasn't really on the left than
there was that that he was too far on the left
and the anti-Semitism was just completely off the
charts. And that was 20 years ago before it was
sort of more OK to be openly anti-Semitic, as it
is now in many cases. So I do think Raskin would
come up against that. But I think he's an
interesting guy, extremely well-spoken. I'm
not going to pretend and say he's sort of the high
energy the the the the picture of like high energy
youth. He's not that, but he's quite a bit
younger than Joe Biden. I think a better speaker,
more of an actual progressive and a very,
very interesting guy. And of course, I'm not
suggesting anything about the 2024 Democratic
primary. The first question is just is Joe Biden
going to run for reelection? I don't think we
have an answer to that yet. When the White House
is asked about it, they say Joe Biden intends
to run for reelection. That's pretty narrowly
worded. I don't know that we can read too much
into it. But Jamie Raskin promises Trump will
get his comeuppance. I hope
he's right. I remain skeptical.